is a small community west of potsdam
one house there in particular with its
reddish brown facade catches the eye
it's home to babette and rudiger kafka
in addition to the main house the 2200
square meter property has two stables
and a barn
this is an island of bliss closed off on
four sides so you can't see in or out we
do our own thing that's livability
limbs qualitative
the farm buildings enclosing the
rectangular courtyard were built more
than a century ago
it's since undergone extensive
renovation
only the old farming tools recall its
original use
it was almost by chance that rudiger
kafka became the owner of the former
farm
he saw it in an ad in the paper
i just picked out one of the little
pictures and thought that one's quite
nice i put in an offer and one day it
was mine i never even saw the property
this is the state it was in back in 1999
while rudy gakafka was unfazed he'd
already fixed up a number of houses in
spain and in 2002 after 18 months of
construction he and babette moved in
yeah this is our living space
the one time farmhouse has 350 square
meters of floor space
just off the dining area is a large
chandelier
south african artists made it out of
objects other people threw away the
kafkas are art collectors their home is
space enough for the 1200 works they own
it
for us art says something about the
environment and the place where the
artist lives and what the artist was
thinking
and that's what we see and are reminded
of when we see it in our space
there's also a work by the owner's
daughter made of crepe paper
upstairs is the largest room of the
house measuring 50 square meters
this here
is this used to be the old farmhouse's
attic where they smoked
now it's our living room
this is where we end the day leave our
cares behind read watch tv whatever
relaxes us
this painting by the hamburg artist
group de
adds even more color to the ambience
the room affords an excellent view over
the property across from the house is
the former barn
during the socialist era the large
building served as a garage for farm
machines today it houses much of the
kafka's art collection
we wanted to let these rooms shine in a
new way
so we filled the space with artworks
that we love each one of which shines in
its own way
right next to the barn is the old hen
house nowadays babette kafka creates her
own pieces here
she specializes in relief-like textures
mounted on used wooden panels
this is my studio this is where i work
and spend as much time as possible
making art
i use different materials like coffee
grounds or sand to give the pictures a
certain materiality
so now where once cows were milked and
pigs were fattened this family has found
a place they can live with their art